I heard you got into gaming during
during this Cove vid lockdown I was I'm
a workaholic so my whole thing like why
everybody was picking up hobbies my
whole thing was to sit down and do
nothing like my therapist was like yo
you just need to chill and find
something that's not attached to that
you're not trying to monetize like
alright so I started playing Call of
Duty and I got really into it like so
into it that I bought a headset I mean
by had said I bought a headset like
years ago and I just found it in my
house I was like ah this is what this is
for I as is so then I'm like in it and
first I wouldn't say anything that
started getting good and I was like
alright yeah I'll put the mic down and
it became a real thing and I thought I
was gonna hear a lot of in words being
thrown around by but just by children
but it was way weirder than that
um I the the biggest thing I heard was a
kid yeah as he was getting is he I got a
kill or something on the game he was
like you didn't even get close to eating
my and I was so confused like it was his
catchphrase coming you even get close to
eating my what kind of brag is that I
don't know and I just sat in my thoughts
like yo what is this kid's life like I
don't like what is what world so he's
just outside like yeah you wanna eat my
but you can't though I bet you can't
even get tops which only means one day
someone would eat yeah yeah yeah yeah no
that taunt tells you a lot there's a lot
going on in there I got to remember that
I gotta I gotta remember that the next
time I'm in an argument with somebody at
a gas station the way this is where I
live
[Laughter]